45 seconds of logos and Cybertron looks
an awful lot like a matte painting of
Tron superimposed over a painting of
course on the Iron City vomited all over
where's Bea 122nd sorry balls just
waiting for my hero cue also in an
opening scene that is pretty much all
computer graphics this staging of this
action is even more egregious than usual
this is a controlled environment where
concern for safety is out the window
along with covering up stunt doubles and
bad takes and they still cut this like
assholes fall backs I believe the look
of confusion on Optimus Prime's mantle
here is that just like the audience he
too can't figure out the difference
between the Decepticons and the Autobots
in these movies I found the planet
that's well hidden earth why is Earth
well hidden and why are you showing a
giant hologram of it in front of the
enemies who could see it you must
protect the planet
if the Decepticons find it then our
people are truly finished but only
bumblebee is going so if the Decepticons
find it and all the other Autobots can
just find somewhere else to go right
like you assholes couldn't have blown
this tower up a lot sooner you've waited
so long to do it that you allowed the
plot to happen and I cannot forgive that
as I watched Optimus Prime we're on on
the top of this tower and which nothing
around it is visible I'm wondering how
did he know that was it septic on flying
by right now that he could jump onto in
case she confused it with Saturn
um did this dude and the very back on
the formation need to use the halt
signal who's he telling to halt here
bumblebee crash lands into earth like a
bomb but he's no more effective at
killing these guys than the paint balls
they're using earlier also in all the
paintball training camps and all the
giant forests and all the world
bumblebee fell right into theirs and
isn't there a safer way for Autobots to
enter a planet than crash landing into
it would someone please explain to me
why you dropped napalm on your own guys
come on this guy knows that was an
a-bomb right if you've been in the
military as long as this character
supposedly has you know you and that
napalm
man why don't you just do this before
Optimus Prime said that earth was well
hidden but the Decepticons find it in
three minutes after bumblebee crashes to
the planet so either Optimus really did
got by showing that hologram earlier or
he's a lying piece of movie wants us to
believe that blitz wing takes the time
to brand the missiles on the fighter jet
he transforms into also how does he even
have missiles where are those stored
when he's running around in Decepticon
form right man you had 10 other valuable
seconds to tell everyone to run and
you've waited until the Decepticon is
about to fire missiles to warn everybody
this is the most worthless run command
since the time I spent all day
incorrectly copying that free program
from computes Gazette on my commodore 64
oh let's wing gives us the bumblebee
Voicebox origin story but inexplicably
throws him down a mountain only to grab
him again to explain why he's going to
kill him hey Bob did you hear what
sounded like two giant alien robot
machines blowing each other up somewhere
nearby yeah but it's fucking lake day
man and I have one rule never be curious
where's my sister
my question is why did you brush your
teeth just before breakfast during
Charlie's introduction we've had to
endure 90 seconds of teen angst to the
tune of bigmouth strikes again and now
she's about to eat some mr. t cereal so
I guess this is the hipster version of
80s nostalgia use the wedding singer but
just as bad for your teeth can you drop
your brother at karate on your way to
work please I could if I had a car from
the moment Charlie walked in everything
about this scene has felt wrong while
the family is probably still recovering
from Charlie's dad's death and it's
still awkward
it appears that new family rules have
started today for no reason then
Charlie's mom inexplicably asked her to
drop her brother at karate but Charlie
has no car it's like this family is
meeting each other for the first time
just this morning I get the whole
putting a Fowler
cheap food item in your mouth can be
sexy but a corndog I guess if I wasn't
circumcised
well hon Charlie works at a place called
Hot Dog on a Stick and I'm wondering why
this place has the policy of making
their only worker manning the booth
deliver food to customers halfway across
the fairgrounds I'm guessing probably
because the awkward hijinks that can
happen but I'm wondering more for
business reasons message I said
character usually a girl shows her
proficiency at cars by knowing something
that a certified mechanic doesn't know
cliche man they really lay it on the B
imagery thick in this movie
shocking they miss the chance to have
Charlie eating Cheerios instead of this
mr. t cereal or chance encounter where
Hailee Steinfeld meets Jerry Seinfeld
saying one of the many hilarious lines
from b-movie that I can't remember
cuz there are so many also how exactly
did bumble be transformed to this
Volkswagen Beetle everything about him
was failing after Blitzwing fucked him
up and he was still able to transform
this somehow works we know he's planning
to establish a base tell us where did I
wouldn't shatter just go where they sent
blitz wing seems like that would be a
good starting point that's B 127 signal
so Charlie just happened to turn on B
when these two assholes were torturing
Cliffjumper on fucking Saturn and
twisting a sword and his chest gave them
a clear signal and Shatter knew it was
bees just by hearing it and why this guy
although Saturn's moons anyway did
Optimus give him the same bull speech he
gave to bubble bee only about Saturn
this week who the sense this doesn't
everybody who watches a show say I want
to watch insert title a show here
tonight and seriously
why does Alf seemingly always appear
when a movie goes back to the 80s Alf
things suck wait a minute if Charlie has
a Polaroid of her and her dad then what
is this picture here did she convert the
Polaroid into a standard picture size
for framing how would you do this back
in 1987 if I get it started I keep it
and I work here every day for a year out
of all the movies I thought bumblebee
would steal from Hymie pay homage to
kristine well it's not one of them but
here we are one two three Hailee
Steinfeld's well she always said that
she was gonna love herself and didn't
need anybody else there's no way that
bee knew that someone else was walking
into the garage and time to convert into
the beetle before they saw him she
didn't even hear the transform anoints
and look I know we're in a hyper
realized world I just choose not to
accept it all so what exactly did
Charlie do when she fixed bumblebee sure
she made the car run but did she also
help him with all that near-death damage
we saw him take earlier
[Music]
he really doesn't but roll credits
smoothie is now had two scenes of people
refusing to move with a large flaming
object is flying right at them from the
sky also this gas station clearly has an
identity crisis here the sign says gas
and guzzlin but the sign above the
station says guzzlin and gas seriously
these asshole transformers need to find
a better way to land on a planet other
than just crashing sure these are
Decepticons but this could have easily
been bumblebee or any number of good
transformers crashing down and killing
lots of people I think I'm just gonna do
this then why were they ever in car for
alien race comes down earth sees like
ten thousand square feet of area and
declares it to suck cliche indigenous
life is even more what exactly are they
basing this on
sure Rory doesn't appear to be anyone's
definition of a winner but they haven't
spent the last two minutes with him
hearing him griping about how grounded
for life sister wouldn't sleep with it
you'd think even evil robots would know
you have to take in a greater sample
size of life-forms before judging the
127th distress signal came from the
western coast of this continent why we
couldn't just land there instead of the
middle of nowhere bump that's the
mystery of transformers anyway glad we
killed that cheating redneck let's get
some pork rinds and it throat I guess
strictly because transformers were never
a toy or cartoon in this universe where
transformers are actually real go BOTS
or king in this universe Michael Bay
makes terrible GoBot movies the point is
I think the success of go bots in this
universe is a definite set also shallow
amusement park employee and potential
love interest lives next door to Charlie
because movie mom took harbouring Conad
to the vet Ron need the station wagon so
many things have duffel at the scene her
mom just steals Charlie's car literally
minutes before she wakes up and she
didn't have time to ask Charlie about it
meanwhile Ron is enjoying breakfast with
Otis but the second Charlie walks out
into the garage he's already halfway to
the station wagon even though he in no
way looked like he was about to go out
the door and neither of these two dicks
even bother to tell Charlie about her
car til she discovered it missing
furthermore this is a classic what did
they do before Charlie bought a car
scenario you mean this asshole Ron
couldn't take his wife's dog debt on the
way to whatever he needed to do with
that station wagon this whole scenario
was manufactured to create conflict
Charlie parks her scooter in the middle
of the road and after a stupid
discussion with her mom gets in the car
to drive and leaves the scooter just
sitting in the road as a hazard or a
free bike for anyone who's feeling
really steely today
away Christina Hudson conveniently
recycles dialogue from her unproduced
robot porn script I Robot you James
two of them just made contact in Texas
intel says they're heading west fast
we're going Texas
why Texas didn't he just tell you that
they were in Texas and they were heading
west fast maybe you want to investigate
whatever they did in Texas but they
aren't there anymore are they it was
sometime at night when the Decepticons
got here right and they immediately
headed west fast according to the
military even figuring Texas is huge
size wouldn't they be farther than this
by now none of that makes any sense be
127 signals comm silent if these signals
gone silent what were you planning to do
when you hit the west coast which
encompasses California Oregon Washington
British Columbia Yukon and Alaska why
haven't you discussed this with your
partner already and stupid to say
because you're talking just as loud a
shatter and these guys can hear every
word you're saying was this guy
expecting his robot dog to do here
Optimus is about to get surrounded
anyway so what's the goddamn point of
using your attack dog in the end these
movies are exactly what the Transformers
the movie was a long advertisement for
Tori's because how else is the audience
supposed to remember you throughout your
diving trophies and the diving will be
important in this movie later just out
deep in a 1987 are we here Appetite for
Destruction came out in July 1987 nobody
really cared about it until the next
year in excesses kick album came out in
October of 1987 the Smith Strangeways
here we come was released in September I
grant you it's possible possible she has
those albums in whatever month this is
1987 but wait a minute can we see that
Alice episode they were watching I
remember this episode vividly it was
called you ain't nothin about a hound
dog and it aired February 29th 1988 at
the time of past from 1987 to 88 since
we last saw a year on the screen yes am
i sinning this yes charlie clearly picks
up tape from the bottom middle column of
this box and it's going to be rick
astley but earlier there was no rick
astley in this column when she was
choosing tapes the song that plays is
never going to give you up which is the
ALF of 1980s music references
[Music]
father-and-daughter used to listen to
unchained melody' while working on a
corvette i don't think so anyway at
least they weren't making pottery if we
tell them though they'll just take their
technology to the Russians instead
dr. bumblebee or how I learned to stop
worrying and love the trance
former's also I'm not sure which part of
this is more insane that dr. Powell
thinks the Decepticons can be trusted
enough to use America's satellite
systems or that they would have any
fucking knowledge of the US has issues
with Russia you really want to go down
in history as a man who cost us the Cold
War because going down as the man that
allowed the planet to be turned over to
alien robots is so much better on a
resume dude I definitely believe working
up the courage to ask the neighbor girl
out is a thing but just barging into her
own does that especially when they're
worried any stupid thing they do might
blow their chance no one can know what
you just saw actually with the lack of
boundaries her own family exhibits
throughout this movie I wonder how they
haven't heard strange noises and
investigated or simply just walked in on
her talking to her alien robot car the
movie is treating her mom's near-miss
like a one-time thing no one can know
what you just saw you promise yeah power
of boners will allow many secrets to be
kept and also give one the ability to
knock their pants when a car turns into
a giant robot in front of them
they're combining our technology
seamlessly satellites phones computers
well a public use of the Internet as we
know it didn't happen until 1989 or so
surely dr. Powell knows that the
technology he's so excited about right
now is already possible this is like
Paul Rudd getting excited about time
travel when we know his 26 year old self
keeps traveling a year into the future
to kill his older self and take his
place it's revolutionary this is the
best Transformers movie since the first
one there possibly period but I'm still
sinning the fact that they couldn't
resist infecting this with yet another
version of agent Simmons he's a weird
guy
you know what's that about Paul could we
just stop trying to make John Cena the
comedian of thing in this movie yourself
aren't you
and it sure is convenient all these
specific songs are playing on a radio
station when he needs them to be I mean
I guess it's possible that he's just
playing songs from some 1980s iTunes
library but if that's the case I don't
know why the radio dial has to move to
certain stations for him to speak if you
told me this movie started off as a
cheap Greg Louganis biopic and some
Hollywood producer read it and said but
we can make a Transformers movie out of
it I would believe you this car is an
embarrassment you should have your dad
buy you a better one sorry movie didn't
have enough conflict with Transformers
battling each other in humans so I'm
glad
to add in some pointless tena Charlie
jabbing for good measure
damn took totalling this car for an
alarm to go off you're telling me this
car is only going 35 miles per hour at
the time memo says this if so why did
the cop clearly see them going well over
60 here this movie is thankfully less
than two hours something that the other
17 Transformers movies didn't have the
restraint to do but with the Charlie
doesn't dive scene wanton destruction of
private property and speeding scenes
this movie includes we could have shaved
about 20 minutes off this puppy - after
what happened last night looking for you
this also means I guess she never
registered this car because cops should
be able to find it strictly through that
but why worry about license and
registration and a movie like this am I
supposed to believe that Charlie thinks
he can eat the pop-tart and or needs to
eat because if so she's just been
letting him starve this whole time
Mooney doesn't know how to dog since
there's no way this pop-tart isn't
already eaten homebound high jinks does
this movie ever actually get to
bumblebee he crashes into this TV and
somehow pong starts playing without
anyone turning on the system or the TV
itself and while this family has a
never-ending budget to buy all the
latest albums they somehow have an
upgraded to an NES yet this is basically
the et gets drunk scene and et except
Charlie doesn't unleash a bunch of frogs
on a science class and doesn't get to
kiss Erica Eleni act I'm just gonna
point out here that the decepticons plan
to take all our technology to find
bumblebee would have turned up nothing
if he didn't suddenly get the urge to
snoop around Charlie's house and stick
his finger in an electrical socket
awesome I know that what's robot got to
do with it told her partner that
bumblebees signal was off but since
we've seen him fire up a hologram and
he's constantly using the radio to find
a way to communicate if that didn't give
off a signal what did its memo
you gotta come home right now Charlie
felt like it was such an emergency she
made sure to change out of her work
clothes before leaving about your car
that you spend all day and nights shut
in that garage doing god knows what with
um what does Charlie's mom accusing her
Oh exactly
there's this hole that I like the
darkest nights produce the brightest
stars it's never gotten me laid before
but I'm thinking eventually it has to
hi I tried getting this information by
torturing the lift jumper guy earlier
but instead of working him over some
more they killed him then they traveled
from Saturn to earth and went through a
whole bunch of just ask bubble be the
same questions he's way more unlikely to
answer than the last dude was know when
I was going through puberty I stole
things to being wrong
hilarious line for sure but her hands
are nowhere near where you say they are
as a kid of the 80s I can tell you with
that most certainty that no one had a
poster of John Carpenter's The Thing the
movie didn't do well and wasn't even
talked about until many years later no
one watched it no one talked about it
bumblebee still alive that's where
they're keeping him well good thing you
walked over to memos place right is the
most important part of this newscast was
playing also movie expects us to believe
that memo is a teenager who would just
be hanging out in his room watching the
fucking news last chance
why is it his last chance are you
expecting some other lucky signal from
space to give you another lead so you
can fruitlessly tort or some other
Autobot about the rebel base yeah this
is a good idea
oh sure this base holds the first known
existence of alien life but nobody's
around to guard it despite the news
telling us earlier that a ton of
military people were coming to Brighton
Falls for some unknown reason you'd
think they'd have enough personnel for
this simple task but you'd be wrong
holy they got into the most highly
classified area of the base too we miss
the scene where Charlie and memo iced a
bunch of America's finest soldiers
[Music]
walkie death kick is lucky fight armed
regroup rebuild why does this recording
even exist other than to give the
Decepticons entirely an easy way to
learn what's going on optimus told bee
everything before he sent him off to
earth that optimists have a what if B
loses his memory after a fight with
Blitzwing and John Cena back-up plan in
place and it's gonna get messy quick
calling the bukkake experts also drop
kick prime won't be here until the
sequel sure in the actual 80s he would
have been in this movie but it's the
2010s and we've got film universes and
these things have to be spaced out so we
can bitch on Twitter about it burn the
whole planet
and we'll be sure to kill dr. Powell as
soon as he gets done radioing this to
John Cena so I see no problem talking
about this out loud
all yours why is pawel hero alone I get
that they were giving shatter and
dropkick access to the satellites to
find B but there's no way they wouldn't
always have a group of soldiers with
them shatter and dropkick didn't hear
this the scene would be a hundred
percent more effective if I wasn't aware
that there were five god-awful
Transformers movies that take place
after this and bumblebee is all over
that I see bumblebee went to the iRobot
school of I color changing when going
from good to bad that I've heard so much
about also isn't it great that after he
nearly died and got shot by a bunch of
electrical guns he suddenly got all his
powers back agent burns survives this he
goes on this super rampage of blowing
but manages to not kill one person
thereby keeping his good guys status
this is like that scene in t2 when
Arnold Schwarzenegger fires a bunch of
grenades at the cops at Cyberdyne and
purposely misses just enough not to kill
anyone but all an accident
instant Decepticons find earth people
yes but the Decepticons only realized
that earth was important because of this
very message they didn't know earth was
the new base until dropkick umm
drop-kicked bumblebee and the hologram
of you popped up three Decepticons so
far have found earth but it meant
nothing sorry for the trivialities here
what Optimus really meant was that the
Decepticons learned that earth was to do
base it would be back I wanna buy some
time with these guys oh just outside
MacKinnon airbase this movie has more
convenient newscast than happy deathday
and die hard to combine we'll save you
the vomit that occurs right after this
because the movie sure should have also
not to be outdone by The Fast & Furious
films next summer we'll get the Otis and
ROM movie where they get called in by
the government for no logical reason to
help them stop a scientifically enhanced
former government agent played by Jaleel
White preparing satellizer to transmit
our message sure bumblebee gets his
power turned on briefly and his signal
immediately goes to Saturn but these
dicks have to waste a bunch of time with
an earth satellite to transmit a message
to their own people
dumpster is made of the same material as
the refrigerator in the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull I'm sure someone's winning
here let's see the blue one kicked a
yellow one and then got slammed into the
thing so carry the one - the five
yep definitely don't know lore give it
if impossibly avoiding flying debris is
a skill charlie has it in spades it's at
this point that I'm reminded that the
Decepticons were given permission to
take over phone lines and satellites to
create the internet and find bubblebeam
and while that basically did nothing to
help them find him having a drawl over
those satellites would have been amazing
for them to transmit this message I'm
not quite sure where they couldn't just
tap into that technology again instead
of waiting for a slow-ass radio tower to
do it for them but that's your typical
third act Bowl for him also this - and
percent bothers me it bothers me a lot
also again when they went to earth did
they not tell any of their superiors
that's where they were going after the
first one that came down and killed
bumblebee died it's crazy they haven't
sent more Decepticons down here after
shatter and dropkick located bees signal
all I have to shoot are bullets right
now I mean sure I have missiles but why
bother if they had just made Charlie a
former gymnast instead of a diver the
sequence becomes at least 67% more
believable wish writers realized that
sometimes it's the little things that
matter most oh there's my missiles
talking about the bullets earlier
I mean you fired earlier probably killed
someone in but I guess we're cool now
high five shadow jumps down from the top
of the tower and then transforms into a
jet I have to stay in your robot form
and slice Charlie up instead of
impotently staring at her in jet form
and shatters somehow thinks that she's
going to shoot Charlie when there's
vulnerability Sheen equipment here that
she needs and could destroy but why do
anything smart when we need bumblebee to
save the day
this entire finale reminds me of Iron
Man 3 you could splice scenes from it
into this one and no one would notice
thank God Charlie's diving finally pays
off the movie could have simply not put
diving in this at all but why do that
when you can make your movie stupid by
the way what exactly does Charlie do to
get bumblebee out of here
he's clearly is still alive and needs no
assistance not like she could have
pulled him out of the water herself so
she doe for no reason hey soldier
everyone driving on the bridge sees this
right Charlie could have tried a more
secluded spot for this farewell Thank
You boys
where the fuck did he find all those
talk shows at the same time to make a
coherent sentence he's been
communicating exclusively through song
but luckily they hit the talkshow
jackpot at whatever time this is well I
guess everyone else will because I have
no clue why the government is shocked
when these things show up again in 2007
I was really hoping these two kids would
find each other in the end what's his
name again
old friend you kept this planet safe did
you though Optimus did you though does
no one watch the skies for a living
anymore and when all these assholes land
won't this get detected by the Richter
scale
we come in base
starving that's your trouble Larry it's
where your sales are always behind quota
you didn't seem to eat is stronger than
your infant's don't win charlie don't
sir
she let you die Grenada I was there when
family Grenada
I saw it all go down at Grenada fish
you're jumping today huh no buffer me
money power to promise me offer me
everything now yes Father
general Kenobi years ago you served my
father in the Clone Wars now he begs you
to help him in his struggle against the
Empire